this is not a scene from December 2020
before widespread covid-19 vaccination
it is from China in December 2022
hospitals and funeral homes struggling
to deal with China's largest ever surge
of covid-19 cases the hospital is just
overwhelmed from top to bottom so you
know the the ER filled up with people
the financial times reports that Beijing
officials privately estimate 250 million
Chinese people contracted the virus in
the first 20 days of December I'm
exhausted this ER doctor tells Chinese
State tv even the much lower official
numbers of cases and deaths are now
unknown China has simply stopped
publishing figures and it has said a
higher bar for what constitutes a covert
death the wave comes just weeks after
China began to dismantle its strict zero
call with strategy first introduced
almost three years ago the changes
following a series of protests from a
very weary population president Xi
Jinping has asked officials to do
whatever is feasible to save lives in
this wave but beijing's 180 yawn zero
covid continues a pace on January 8
hotel quarantine will end for passengers
arriving on international flights
China's full vaccination rate is high
but less so among seniors and studies
indicate its domestic vaccines are much
less effective at preventing serious
cases last week the World Health
Organization said it believes China is
looking at registering a western mRNA
vaccine we would certainly encourage
that kind of work the true long-term
impact of China's strategy will only
become clear in time right now many
Chinese people are dealing with concerns
and fears many of us first faced more
than two years ago Redmond Shannon
Global News London